voila
avec le Diez ciento troisième important
vous êtes curieux d'habitude
alors ils décident de jouer à l'extérieur cette foire
pourriez-vous marcher le café elle utilise
un couteau baku-pod mais quand Jeff est chez
Denny's le jour de l'amusement acaba de fair lady
ferrozzo va être FINA voir si  ton Paso
sexuel notre chien hé regarde Fatima un
diamant solide oscille a las tu vois un
dodo
pas Amy Pond ocotilla si profondément en toi
avant que je montre un placebo Chiana dit que nous une
façade ou une réponse motrice innovante
après triste je ne ferais jamais un film fait
si je vivais comme ça je ne bois pas je ne
prends pas de pilules je ne kidnappe pas de gin tu
sais je veux dire c'est pas ma vie comment il
a une vie de dingue mais alors là je suis
différent mais philosophiquement pareil je
ressens le  de la même manière à propos de la religion de la
même manière à propos de la science ou de la philosophie l'
esthétique le sexe il
y a 20 ans il y a 25 ans je me sentais
comme ça je sentais que je n'étais pas concentré avec
mes amis ma famille mes collègues
ou pairs qu'ils avaient tous une bonne concentration
sur  la vie dans laquelle ils étaient et que j'étais perdu que
je n'étais pas je ne pouvais pas me concentrer c'est
tous les américains quand ma sexualité
vibre apollyon poker typique
j'expédierai un affreux Peabody gon pass ot
répertoire Sao Paulo enterré avec cet
effort commercial
oh mon  mère aurait pu rapidement machiner ma
phrase ou est-ce que nous avons choisi la console de caste pour
gagner un diplôme, elle nous a laissé tirer là-bas
Je veux juste travailler avec lui Je veux
voir comment c'était et la bonne nouvelle
est que c'était génial même si j'étais  un
effet spécial c'était bien il m'a laissé
improviser j'ai dit euh ils ont dit que c'était
très bien vous en avez d'abord pris je suis
content qu'est-ce que vous voudriez
essayer quelque chose et j'ai improvisé pour
prendre et je l'ai vu rire et ça  c'est
que pour moi c'est moins cher que le Prozac
Nikki